If you just took your life like a pie
and look at the amount of energy that's available,
how much of the time are you sitting with a tree,
like dropping in?
(upbeat music)
Life is miraculous.
And there are things that go on in this body
that science can't explain.
It's a precious gift to be here
and transformation is happening,
but it's our job to hold the highest vision.
When we think about intelligence,
we tend to think about it
in the context of rational intellect.
And of course, that is certainly a source of intelligence,
but what about things like intuition,
feelings, gut, instincts?
These are overlooked in that conversation,
and yet have their place and shouldn't be ignored.
We're here to elaborate on this notion
is Julie Piatt, aka SriMati,
returning for her,
I don't know how many times she's been on the show,
her umpteenth appearance on the podcast.
In addition to being my wife,
and for those new or newer to the show,
Julie is many things.
She's a Yogi, a musician, a vegan chef,
she's the mother to our four children,
she's also the bestselling author of three vegan cookbooks.
She's the host of the For the Life of Me podcast.
She is the priestess of Water Tiger,
her online spiritual for immunity.
And she's also the founder and CEO of Sri Mu,
the best plant-based cheese in the universe.
Yes, I am biased.
Nonetheless, this is the fact.
As many of Julie has been a recurring source
of spiritual wisdom on the podcast,
dating all the way back to episode one.
And today we continue that trend
with a conversation about heart's intelligence.
We talk about motherhood, the many benefits of yoga,
the power of neutrality.
We discuss the importance of community
and entrepreneurship and many other topics,
including her obsession with WSU people.
Final note as a gift for all of you guys for a limited time,
Julie was kind enough to offer 15% off all Sri Mu orders
when you visit srimu.com,
that's S-R-I-M-U.com and use the code spring 15 at checkout.
Okay, please hit that subscribe button
and way we go with the multi-talented and wise,
Julie Piatt.
Here we are once again.
In our happy place.
That's right.
The most recurring guests in our RP history
back again to share wisdom.
I believe the last time you were here,
that episode went up in October of 2021,
but we probably recorded it
quite in advance of that.
So that it's probably been like, I don't know,
between six and nine months since you've sat across from me.
Has it really been that long?
I think so, yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah, so I'm excited to, once again,
take a state of affairs of our marriage,
talk about parenting, share a little bit of wisdom,
catch up on your entrepreneurial SRIMU adventures.
But today is a special day,
because it's Tyler's 27th birthday today, your eldest.
That's right.
It is the anniversary of when I became a mother.
So when a baby is born,
there are two births that occur,
the birth of the child and the birth of the mother.
And so I was reborn with all of my children,
but Tyler is the first being to have made me a mother.
So does that leave you reflecting on motherhood?
Yeah, well, I'm glad that we have him close.
I'm glad to have him in my life.
And he's an extraordinary human
and someone who is multi-layered,
very creatively talented, musical, loving,
thoughtful, insightful, very well read,
he's a very kind, beautiful soul,
and I cherish all the moments that I get to be with him.
Yeah, I would second that.
And I would add that
it's been fantastic to have him and Trapper home
throughout the pandemic, I've said it many times.
But they, the two brothers had moved out
and were living in Echo park and in apartment.
And when the lockdowns began and all of that, two years ago,
they moved back home, they're still home.
And that's been this beautiful silver lining
to have them around.
And I think it's been very beneficial
for the younger kids also.
And just for us, like would've not been able to continue
to develop our relationship
to the extent that we've been able to,
had they been living in town
where you get to see them once every two weeks or something.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, it's been, you know,
I keep saying that we're gonna look back on this and cherish
the sort of extra time that we have shared together.
And also I think it sort of brings back
the extended family as a form of community.
And in the modern world,
it's very challenging to be entrepreneurs,
be in the world,
be serving different initiatives,
creative expressions, have still young kids at home,
manage the teenage dragons,
navigate world events without having a strong community
and so they offer a lot.
And they did and were a part of our financial transformation
and that whole journey that we went through,
they were part of our team.
And without them, we would not have emerged so beautifully.
Yeah, I mean, they're old enough
that they have solid memories of every phase of this thing
that we've been on.
Whereas the younger ones can't really remember
what it was like during some of the harder parts.
Mean, Mathis probably remembers aspects of it.
Jaya certainly doesn't.
Yeah, Mathis remembers quite a bit of it
from her context of being 6, 7, 8, 9, something like that.
But what's happening is the awareness that Jaya doesn't even
really remember those early years,
the early, early homeschool years.
And most of Jaya's are remembrance is,
the appearance of social media
and what part that has played.
So it is interesting also as a mother,
I don't know if you reflect on this as a father,
but I realized a bit ago
that I've been a different mother to each child.
Like when you think,
oh, I'm a mother,
and you develop this kind of idea in your mind,
well, I'm this kind of mother,
but if you really look at it
as the evolution of time continues,
you're a different mother with every child.
And especially if you have four or five children,
by the time you get to the end, you are a different mother.
The environment is different, everything's transformed.
it's a different set of variables
and that's been interesting to reflect on.
Yeah, I think that's certainly true.
And it's brought up
a lot over the last two years,
as we're trying to usher two teens into young adulthood,
it's definitely had it's bumps.
It's been a roller coaster ride.
I just shared on the roll on the other day,
the challenges that,
that Jaya has sort of experienced over the last couple weeks
that have brought me as a father
to my maker in terms of how to parent a child
through disappointment, extreme disappointment,
and the kind of psychic pain that occurs of course,
within the child, but also within the parent,
this sense of powerlessness to solve the problem.
My masculine energy wants to just fix it.
I can't fix it.
It's just about holding space
and doing my best to refrain from projecting
whatever patterning is embedded in my psychic
as a result of the way that I was brought up,
in a way that is potentially damaging for the kid,
so it's interrupting that pattern.
And you've been really good with me to try to call me out
when I'm doing that or make me notice things
that otherwise I would just do automatically.
Well, I mean you're a beautiful father
and you've been there for Jaya as you are for all your kids
and for all of us.
I think that the journey with our children,
and again, as every single crisis, every spiritual crisis,
every kind of conflict,
the answer only resides inside of you.
It only, the answer is only in here.
It's not out there.
And again, we receive these experiences
and they're paralleling our own experiences
of our childhood.
So what I would say is that in a way,
you're trying to manage your own pain
from your own pain of being disappointed in school
and being left out
and not feeling like you belonged anywhere.
And these are patterns
that have existed within your life print
for a very, very, very long time.
So it's loaded, it's really, really, really static.
So when you say the answer is within you,
the problem with that is a lack of conscious awareness
of the patterning.
Like yes, the answer...
So in my instinctual response
is to mimic the pattern
and you have to disassociate from that
in order to understand
that you're like running a loop
as opposed to taking a higher consciousness approach
to the issue.
Well, and let's just say like the very plainly,
like it's been an ass kicker recently,
so let's just say that outright
so that other people
that are going through their own alchemical fire
of transformation.
I mean, you and I had a couple spaces
in the last two weeks,
where we were literally in the fire
and in the fire between the two of us
and then in the fire,
because of what one of our children is going through,
who we love deeply.
And I feel that the,
when I say the answer is within us parents,
as long as we have unresolved issues within our own being
that we have managed to avoid,
to deny, to put a band-aid on,
to put a boar on,
meaning like a dress on,
that is yours to reconcile, it's not...
Otherwise, they will continue to manifest.
Yeah, and it's not your child to job to resolve that.
And possibly the, the,
the denial of resolving the issue
is what brings the child to create that situation.
It's almost like they're the master Gurus,
they're the Jade eyes
and they come into your life and they're more evolved
as evolution goes, they're more expanded.
And so it's almost a gift on a soul level
that Jaya has brought this reflection into your experience.
Because it's forcing me to look at something
that I would much prefer to bury and pretend doesn't exist.
That's it.
And the thing is this,
what can we not avoid pain in our children, that we,
we might be able to avoid pain in ourselves,
but we can't avoid pain in our children.
And so it is upon the parents as individual beings
to take responsibility for our own pains and traumas
and do the work sincerely be like an explorer, an excavator,
and really look at those patterns,
and really get into clearing them
so that the children can be free
to have their own experience.
Yeah, I mean, I think in this particular case,
when I was Jaya's age, when I was 13, 14,
I definitely suffered from feeling like an outsider,
not knowing where I fit in,
being bullied and everything that gets packed into that.
And of course,
when I see my child enduring some version of that,
it's gonna bring that up, right?
And I feel like I've grown a lot.
And yet what it has presented is,
or illuminated is the fact that
I haven't completely healed that.
And there's more healing to be done for myself
so that I don't project that kind of pain
onto my child and make it worse.
Definitely.
Yeah.
And how do we heal those types of pain?
We all have the, we all have our version of this.
Of course, talking about it
is one level of identifying the problem,
but clearing the pain does not come from talking about it.
It comes from meditation,
from mirror-work, from breath-work,
from these experiential techniques that you can enter
into that will actually clear the energy from your being.
So if I was to come to you and say,
and I didn't know you, and I said,
oh, you're this person
who might be able to help me with this,
here's what's going on.
And I explain what I just explained.
What would the protocol be that you would suggest?
If you were to come to me.
Yeah.
Well, this is kind of curious.
I mean, it's kind of interesting,
because I just did two sessions
for two individuals for life issues
before I arrived here to the interview.
And isn't it interesting how I'm living in your house.
And I have a whole portal of techniques
that lead one to these issues
and you have not partaken,
you have not drunk from the fountain.
I don't like to do this kind of stuff
until I'm in so much pain that I have no choice.
That's another like meta pattern or broader pattern.
Well, again, it could be that I'm not your healer
and that could be fine.
I mean, there's thousands of beans all over the world.
I don't think it would be appropriate.
Well, that's one perspective,
but one might also say that possibly
I have been your healer from day one.
No, you definitely, you have been that, yes.
I think you wrote a book about that a little bit, but...
Yeah, that book was dedicated to a certain individual.
It was sort of thing and thank you for that,
but I guess, we're getting sort of to, and I'm, excuse me,
'cause my voice is fried.
I was out on a spiritual mission for the last week
and my voice is a little tapped,
so I'll try to speak
in a way that it's not cracking, but...
Okay, intellectual conversation is wonderful.
It's amazing and it really is important
for us as humans to bond and connect
and be inspired.
And then there is a whole other universe of transcendence
that happens in the processes of technique.
And you cannot transcend by talking about it.
It will only lead you to a certain place.
And we see this demonstrated
in our sessions of holotropic breathing
when we're on retreat
and you see humans go into a breathing space.
And there are people
who have almost never practiced yoga before
and they have transcendent experiences.
You have witnessed it yourself.
Yeah, there are literally psychedelic experiences
that people are having.
Literally, and again, it's like,
I worked with somebody today who came to me, who said,
I feel like my life has almost passed me by
and I have failed to access the spiritual part of who I am.
And just in one session,
she has such an awareness of her spiritual nature.
Given the space, humans are connected to their spirituality.
We are truly, I heard you say it recently,
I'm a spiritual being, having human experience.
Right, but you help that person unlock that
and find a path forward.
I mean, it's a result of you having a conversation
with that person.
So the talking about it is at least an initial piece.
It's a portal, yeah, it's a portal.
And then the other half my sessions are talking,
so they're talking, how can I be of service to you?
Where are you?
What's going on?
And I go through family history,
physical history environment,
relationship with spirituality, everything,
addictions, sexual abuse, anything.
Then after we've identified,
then we drop into the technique.
So it's not,
I'm not like a therapist where you just talk,
and then I say, time's up, you gotta go.
And even so water tiger is this technique,
is this portal of techniques,
which are designed to lead you
into a deep relationship with your own being,
because your life is about you and you alone.
It's not about my life.
And it's not about any of the kids' life.
It's about you and you alone.
And you have, we all have the opportunity
to choose our sovereign connection to our spiritual nature.
And what would those technics be?
Oh, they're huge,
I mean, they're massive.
I mean, there's, well, there's like 40,
maybe in the portal right now.
They consist of all different ones.
So one might be taking your divine consciousness,
like the gaze in a meditative state,
through the body on a journey
where it connects all of the organs,
all of the systems,
all of the glandular systems, cells, mitochondria,
to all communicate with each other.
So you're tracking light all over your body
so that it's all on.
Because if you ask somebody to think of themselves,
they may just think of their head and their shoulders.
Or how often are you
consciously aware of the back of your body?
Are you living there?
Like when you walk in the room,
are you embodied in the back of your body?
So that's an embodiment technique.
So there's a bunch that are like that.
Then there are more devotional ones,
that are about dropping into the beauty of life
and connecting with the one breath that is breathing us.
There are devotional prayers.
There are techniques
that lead you to drop into the black fullness.
It's empty-full space.
It's not empty space.
But it's the void where you can replenish
in that meditative state and gather energy in that state
and others are for amplifying presence,
amplifying your presence in your body,
there's a saying that if you don't embody your life print,
meaning your physical body and your energetic bodies,
something or someone else will.
So meaning, you could have an ancestral pattern
that is living inside of your life print,
because you have not embodied that,
you have not claimed your energy back.
Right, so to put a finer point on that,
an example would be in my own case,
me perpetuating a pattern that was imprinted on me
by my mother or my father, or the way that I was raised,
such that I'm not conscious that I,
in furtherance of this unhealthy behavior pattern
and not totally aware of the fact that
it isn't actually me.
It's the result of neural pathways that got cemented
when I was a very young person
and thus feel reflexive as opposed to consciously chosen.
Yeah, it's an automatic pattern.
We call it a mayasm, that is basically running in you.
So it means your sovereignty is not activated.
And then you end up doing the exact same behavior
that you hate it.
Promised that you won't.
Literally, hated as a child.
To your child.
And you're not a, you know, this is not a,
I mean, this is everyone, this is what we do.
And then you're like, oh my God, I'm acting like my mother.
Oh my God.
So the point is that,
I always say, of anything that transformed my life
in a positive way, in a transcendent way,
it was the practice of yoga, physical asana,
which you and I met in that environment.
And it's not the same as running,
I applaud every athlete and all their journeys
and all the incredible people that you have on the show
they're like mind blowing, and all of it's amazing.
And getting into a yoga practice,
which connects you to this consciousness that is holding.
And I'm sure that in athletic pursuits,
like I saw you at the end of Ultraman,
you were in your divinity.
One of the most beautiful sites of you
is at the end of Ultraman.
Literally, like to the end of my days,
I will take that glorious image in my heart.
Absolutely extraordinary,
because you were bare raw of anything,
that was a padding.
And that's when I see you in your period.
Right, I mean, the similarities or the parallels
would be that endurance sports strip you down
because you're forced to confront yourself
in your most physically and mentally vulnerable.
Like it's so hard that when you complete a race
or a training session,
you had to burn through all those layers.
And that's one of the beautiful kind of growth arcs
that I've been on as a result of being an endurance athlete
is that it was this vehicle
or this crucible for confronting myself
in a way that I hadn't yet,
even as somebody who'd been sober for a long time.
Yoga is similar, but it's also qualitatively different.
And it's a modality that its own unique thing.
And yoga techniques are shelter from the storms.
Like Shama came over our friend and she said,
I've been practicing yoga.
And I said, you know only thing you have to do every day?
She said, what?
I said, practice yoga.
It's really the only thing you have to do,
no matter what's happening.
If the world is ending, practice yoga.
It creates an awareness of energy,
that is beyond space and time.
It empowers your energetic,
it expands your ability to live free.
And I'm not saying go into a yogic sect
and get into all the lineage and all the teachings.
I'm just saying, just get on the mad,
develop a meditation practice and ask ourselves like,
those of us who have apps who say they meditate
and are running around.
I mean, really, like how much are you really meditating?
Are you really meditating or are you listening to a podcast?
Are you reading more news?
Like if you just took your life like a pie,
and look at your energetic,
the amount of energy that's available,
how much of the time
are you engaged in intellectual activities?
Pontificating, analyzing, judging, assessing, summing up,
like on a daily basis,
in this Coliseum of life that we find ourselves in now?
And how much time have you been in nature?
Have you stopped?
Are you connecting with your breath?
And I mean, being in nature, not listening to a podcast,
not listening to music, dropping in, sitting with a tree,
like dropping in, like, are we communicating on that level?
Are you talking to me specifically?
Kind of, yeah.
I feel attacked.
No, don't feel attacked
Yeah, no, I hear that.
And I'm certainly...
I certainly plead guilty to being in action,
and living in my head and intellectualizing things
and trying to solve problems with my mind
and diluting myself into the idea
that my consciousness is behind my eyes,
like that idea.
And it's a challenge
and it's difficult for me to carve out the time
and create the boundary for the thing
that you prioritize much more than I do.
Well, I think, it's very fitting
and it's very relevant
as a conversation right now, just globally.
Because I feel there is a war over consciousness through,
between these two camps.
And we have had this war in our own house.
So it's the intellect that wants to define, analyze,
make someone right, make someone wrong,
come up with a solution.
And then you, jump on that solution.
Like this is the solution or so and so said this
or this expert said that.
And so this is the right diet, or this is the right view,
or this is the right country or.
And all of that is nonsense.
Actually in the truth of the matter,
we all come from one breath.
And what I'm saying is both are needed.
But the problem in this particular place at this time,
a lot of energy is given to the intellect.
And once again, the feminine is canceled,
is reduced, is made unimportant
or thought to be uneducated
or unwise or uninformed.
And really all of this feeling, intuition,
the ability of mothers, the ability of women,
of the feminine force to lead, to guide,
to lift communities up,
to find a way where all are cared for,
this is the great shift that we're going through right now.
And we're not there.
I mean, we're not there, but it's changing.
So there's a lot in that.
I mean, this is definitely a recurring thing in our house.
'cause I am that guy who will resort
to the intellectual take on issue X
versus the intuitive feeling into the heart,
higher consciousness version of understanding.
Well, not only you it's both the boys,
the boys are highly intellectual
and very well read, they're extraordinary.
They know everything about everything.
But when there's even like a,
a sort of joke
about when someone talks about their feelings, it's like,
oh, it doesn't matter what you feel,
like look at the facts.
That's always the trajectory,
but the truth of the matter is,
the real intelligence in the body lives in the heart.
And your body knows if something is in alignment,
if something is false,
if something is trying to prey on you,
if you are able to drop into your body,
which this is what yoga gives you.
And connect with your breath,
you can understand that many things in this life
might look shiny on the outside,
but you have to be more mature than that.
You have to be able to feel
into what's really going on with the energy.
But your vessel must be pure,
because I think a lot of people will say,
I feel this way,
or this is how my heart is telling me X,
but they haven't done the internal excavation
to be in a place where their intuition,
their instinct and their hearts' messaging
is necessarily trustworthy,
because it's equally imposed by those past patterns
or traumas, pains, life experiences,
that color what that intuition feels like.
Definitely, I mean, there's a spectrum.
I'm not saying that everyone who has a feeling
has worked through all of their trauma.
And that feeling is necessarily balanced and integrated in,
merged with their consciousness.
But also that's not for us to judge or analyze or regulate,
because each one of us is a completely individual life form.
So that might be a step in that person's journey.
So it's diverse.
I mean, the levels of feelings
and the levels of intellectual opinions are vast.
All I'm saying is in the general cadence of life.
If one cancels the feminine aspects
of feeling intuition, sensing.
You said to me the other day
I don't think you realize, you don't realize what a crisis,
our child is in.
And I was like, excuse me.
I gave birth to this child.
And it's in every cell of my body, I'm well aware of it,
extremely aware with it, keenly aware of the pain.
So my point is is we gotta stop.
We gotta stop with this impulse to overpower the feminine,
as if the feminine is not valid.
And what I will say again is both are needed.
I love masculine energy, I have masculine energy in me.
I'm utilizing it right now.
I have masculine energy.
You have feminine energy.
Everybody has both.
It's about both are needed.
And without both,
we aren't going to be led in a balanced way.
That's more what I, more the point.
So to go ground this in?
In intellectual.
Now, I'm gonna, intellectualize this.
No, I hear you.
I understand, I mean,
this is an ongoing conversation in our house and it's been,
a catalyst for my own growth
and developing a higher awareness,
and trying to figure what a more conscious approach
to my life and our children would look like.
So in the example of our youngest and this disappointment.
And me coming to you and saying, I think,
me having the masculine impulse of like,
we need to solve of this,
we need to understand like what's actually going on,
how are we moving forward?
What's the plan?
And you having a very different,
not only intuitive response to it,
but also a very different manner in terms of
how you're communicating with Jaya
versus the way that I've approached it.
So I think it's just,
it would be instructive to like highlight those differences
as an example of what you're talking about.
Yeah, so, first all extremely painful
for me to witness my child with this disappointment.
Also because what was also quite shocking is
all the members of the family had this absolute certainty
of another outcome.
So it was shocking to all of us,
literally, like not what we thought was gonna happen.
The pain of seeing your child in pain is real.
I mean, I've felt it in every cell of my being,
the same way that you did.
My point is that as powerful, universal creators
worrying is praying for what we don't wanna happen.
So we have a love one child literally on the floor.
And so then if we go in and call out the suffering,
and then supercharge that with all of our unresolved shit
around the same thing,
then what that does is that piles on top of the person.
It does In fact, the opposite of what our intention is.
You are a beautiful father, you love your kids so much.
Like this is not about that.
So I rather,
even though I'm being burned inside by the fire,
because as it's so intense,
I consciously make the decision to hold an outcome
that is expansive.
And that is not easy, it takes intention,
all the tools that I've developed.
That's why they say you should learn to meditate
when you're well,
because when your body gets sick or a war breaks out,
or there's real shit going on, you gotta be the warrior.
Like it's not that you just skip through the field and like,
smell a Daisy and you're not paying attention.
That's the work.
That's what you have to do.
So my point was let's hold this higher.
I'm like, okay, I'm so shocked.
I didn't think this gonna happen.
I'm still in disbelief,
but let's hold a vision.
This has to be leading to something better, it has to be.
And I managed to break through and I got little closer
and we shared in this way.
And so that's a blessing.
And then I use that as a little step.
And then I say I was able to cook
and my child received my food.
Okay, another stepped, okay.
They're gonna be okay.
it's going in that direction
while you're over in the corner,
calling out the fire and the disaster
in the horrific thing that's going on.
And you are upset at me
that I'm not in that state of horror with you.
I guess, does that make sense?
Yeah, I think that's a little harsh.
No horror, but...
Cause, I was doing my best to be aware of that patterning
and not foist it.
And I didn't do that perfectly,
but I think I could have handled a little lot worse.
I feel like you're being a little extreme
in terms of how I botched the job.
Okay, no, I'm not.
I'm not saying that you botched the job at all
and understand what I'm saying.
It's not your actions.
It's the energetic memory that was in your body.
That is energy is a thing.
Thoughts are things, feelings are a thing.
So again, you're looking at how did I solve the situation?
And I'm saying from the energetic that's unresolved,
that adds onto it.
Do you understand?
Yeah.
'Cause no, you absolutely didn't botch anything.
This is a process of navigating through relationships
with all of our inherent baggage.
I mean, you could also say that I'm too well-meaning
or that me thinking something's gonna work out,
maybe I need a little bit more action within that.
Practical action.
I think that's the tension between you and I.
That's why we're here.
That's why we have this show.
Yeah, I mean, I can be the planner
and make the list and make sure that
we have all the email addresses and phone numbers
and the people that we need to call
and the strategy
for how we're gonna approach solving this problem.
Then I see you like I'm holding space
and it's gonna be fine
and it's gonna work out.
And I'm like,
yeah, but not without engaging in the active steps
required to manifest that.
Yeah, but to have a problem manifesting?
No, you don't, you don't.
So that's an evolution like, okay.
And can we just say that
less than five days since the event that caused this trauma,
there has already appeared miraculous solution,
that may end up being the reason
that we didn't go down the other path.
Right, yeah, 'cause in the moment,
when you say, well, this thing that we had our heart set on,
that didn't work out it's because there's something better.
And it's so annoying.
And to say that in the midst of the shake going down
and you say I kind of like,
yeah, yeah, but do I really believe that?
See, I really do believe.
Yeah, I know, right?
It's so annoying to me.
Again, it's perspective.
Remember, all events are neutral
until perspective is applied.
Wait, say that again.
All events are neutral until perspective is applied.
So we know half glass, half full glass, half empty.
So again, it's what...
This is the demonstration of that.
It's how we choose to apply our perspective to events
that give them energy in one direction or another.
So when people are in need,
we need to apply the higher perspective,
not denying the pain,
but saying, okay, I'm gonna put my energy in the rising.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is,
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle
and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
are affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes,
everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH@checkout,
this is life changing stuff,
people for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Yeah, I mean, I think in terms of
how I was processing this particular situation internally,
is that when I, and said this,
I serve of alluded to this earlier.
Like when I was that age,
I experienced a certain type of trauma.
And I think in the back of my mind,
as we've gone on this parenting journey,
a huge priority for me was to do everything in my power
to ensure that none of my children
would experience that thing that I experienced,
and then when this event occurred,
that was a version of that,
that I think activated a lot of that,
unresolved pain that I think in my mind, I felt like I had,
I know that I've gone a long way towards resolving,
but it revealed to me
that there are still more layers of that.
Yeah, and again, how well does that go
for any of us as parents?
When we do everything we can
to make sure our child doesn't suffer,
the thing that we suffered?
It's a projection of our unresolved issues onto our kids.
Your kid is your own individual.
It's a different life for him.
It's not living your life.
It doesn't wanna live your life.
Actually, it doesn't even want.
That's for sure.
But this is the pattern that continues.
And when I was trying to convince families
to unschool with me when the kids were little,
this was the thing that blew it up,
was parents projection of their own issues
into the children.
And I think education is a bigger hot button
than politics or religion.
Explain that.
Meaning that when you're dealing with education
of someone's kids,
the emotions run really extreme and intense,
yet, what I'm saying is we're not the only ones.
What I'm saying is that this is like a very,
a very sort of universal, I think, condition.
But again, getting back to here,
we are in a landscape where there is a war
that's highlighted, of course,
there's wars all over the planet going on all the time,
but this particular war is highlighted,
and it's like what?
I was asking myself in my meditation
and in my spiritual group,
water tiger was.
What is the luminary's prayer to suffering?
As a luminary, if I consider myself a luminary
or one of the ones that came here
to hold some fractal of light, like millions of us,
what is the luminary prayer to war?
I mean, what can we do?
We're horrified, we're suffering with, we're not,
we're suffering in our hearts with our fellow humanity.
We're seeing this horrible play unfold
while also hopefully recognizing that this is going on
in many parts of the world,
and what is the luminary's prayer?
So based on what I just shared
in the family lens of relationships,
so what I can do as an individual,
is I can dedicate my meditation to expanding the power
in my energetic field.
And you could, this could be through breath,
through presence, through dropping into the state, the void,
and what I'm doing is I'm amplifying the amount of light
that I'm able to hold.
And then I bring into my heart, this feeling of peace,
of humanity, of love,
of where every human has a safe place to live,
food to eat, place to love of their children.
And I amplify that as much as I can.
And then I say to the one breath,
hear my prayer.
May all my brothers and sisters who are suffering,
feel my presence that I am with them.
And that I hold this vision
for a more expanded life experience together.
And that is a version of a luminary prayer.
And as I just told you,
that could seem trite and silly and ridiculous
to an intellectual,
but thoughts are things.
Energy is something.
And so when I counsel people
who have said goodbye to their loved one,
our culture goes into grief and denial
and no, don't go, don't go, don't go.
And really what we wanna do is support them in their journey
to their next life.
So what we can do is send them blue light,
say, thank you for this lovely life we had together,
have a safe journey, a well journey.
I'll meet you on the other side, go, don't stay.
And I'm gonna send you help.
It's like you're gonna jump out of an airplane
and what's gonna help you,
someone screaming at you, don't go.
No, what's gonna help you is someone going, you got this.
I'm with you.
Like when my dad died, you did great.
You're going on an amazing expedition.
Thank you, we love you.
Thank you, go.
But we aren't taught how to do that.
And so here we are in this landscape
of this world coming off of COVID
and COVID brought up these polarities
and this war over consciousness.
Right, it heightened everything,
it made everything just feel all the more acute.
And I think that enhanced my my reaction
to what Jaya experienced,
because it's been a difficult two years for this kid.
Like these kids in the rooms on Zoom for school
deprived of things
that we have always taken for granted,
experiences that I think are crucial
for young people to have.
And that's a like its own pain body,
that makes me feel like just this one thing.
Why couldn't just that one thing work out?
Yeah, definitely, I mean, and it's a lovely care
that you have, it's beautiful.
And we wouldn't want to take away
the adversarial challenges that our children have.
We talk about it all the time on this show,
how you become from your hardships,
from that it's the adversarial experiences
that shape who you are.
And so we have to find the faith within that
and we have to color it with faith and devotion,
and hold the higher vision,
hold vision of a world where we have transcended,
many of these systems that are coming up for reclamation.
And I don't care.
I mean, listen, nobody knows how it's gonna go.
No one in any camp, in any place,
intellectual, spiritual, nobody knows.
And when you get into the 11th hour to the,
I don't know what term would be,
to the critical moment,
the critical moment when you leave your body,
all you have is this.
I don't have the fact I was married to rich roll
and we did this or that,
or I had SRIMU or I raised four kids or I, whatever.
All I have is this,
this is the technology.
And it's this connection to consciousness, to spirit.
And we all have it free from religion, dogma, isms,
science, free from all of it.
The life is miraculous.
And there are things that go on in this body
that science can't explain.
There are things that go on in the universes
It keeps changing.
You get to a certain status quo, and then everybody goes,
that's the reality.
And then you wait a few years
and then that reality is a different reality.
And that's fine and it's amazing.
And humans are extraordinary,
and all of us matter,
all of us are needed.
And we need to acknowledge the feminine frequency,
which is 50% of the human experience.
It's not just intellectual quantifying of circumstance.
And in Tantra, which is an ancient vertic lineage,
the student asks the master,
are dates good for you to eat?
And the master says,
for whom and when.
That is the answer to every intellectual question.
It's for whom and when, it depends.
How old are you?
Where do you come from?
What's your constitution?
What's your life plan?
What's your instruction set for your life?
What type of body do you have?
Are you healthy?
Are you not healthy?
Are you a large happy being?
Are you a skinny angry being?
Like all of these things matter.
How old are you?
What is the stage of the life that you're in?
I feel like humans are not hardwired
to inhabit that disposition.
And that's why it is a practice
and somethings like meditation and yoga
are so crucial for developing that internal connectivity.
Because humans in our minds
are disposed to pattern recognition.
We're looking for patterns.
Like, oh, these things are always like this.
And so that's the way this is.
And we observe things and we listen and we hear,
and we assemble experiences,
and we try to extract greater truths out of them.
And the practice is about detaching from that
and understanding that that's just a very small piece
of the story of reality.
Which is another way of saying what you just said.
Might not be reality at all.
Actually, yeah.
Quite honestly.
In either camp,
any ideas that I have about meditation,
it's probably not that.
So I'm just saying it would benefit us
to develop some reverence for the great one breath,
the ancient force that is inhabiting all life
and to return to some of the ways of the indigenous
of listening to the winds and the trees,
and the earth and the air and the fires and the animals.
Right, and we're talking about this
with respect to how we parent children,
and also in terms of our relationship with ourselves.
I think it would be valuable
to spend a few minutes talking about
how that operates
in the context of a relationship, a partnership.
Now you wanna get into our relationship?
Yeah, or relationships in general.
No I thought you said our relationship.
Well, no, just extrapolating on these ideas
in the context not extrapolating on these ideas,
not simply in the context of parenting children
or our relationship with ourselves
but in relationship with our partners.
We can use our relationship as an example of that.
I mean, I speak from personal experience,
that's how I'm able to offer the best.
Yeah, me too.
Experience, yeah.
So it's curious, isn't it?
You and me recently, it got out on the internet
that you sleep in a tent
and it sort of became a (indistinct)
New cycle.
Its like we were getting offers to be uncertain news,
shows that we just said no to.
But isn't it curious how you and I found each other,
and we've been together for 20 years.
Remarkable period of time and raised four children,
and have done businesses together
and creative expressions together.
So it's curious that it's an interesting union.
When you think of how we're together
when our cadence of how we walk on the earth
is completely opposite.
I would say the way you put your foot on the earth
and the way I put my foot on the earth
are completely different.
It's different to the level of our digestion,
the foods that nourish you
are different than the foods that nourish me
from an I standpoint.
The temperature that you need is different from mine.
You worship the sun,
and I need to go of mountains in the snow.
So it's been a beautiful gift of life
that brought us together,
that allowed us to have this extreme opposite
sort of combustion.
It creates a friction that creates an alchemy,
that then produces something extraordinary.
And without the friction, it's not quite that way.
And I'm not saying
this is just in this type of relationship
and I think very fitting for the last 20 years.
And in my awareness,
we were brought together to hold this space for others
as an example,
and I think that many have received a lot of benefit
and expansion from us sharing
these very private experiences.
Because we are so different
and other people I think find themselves in that experience.
Yeah, there is a unique alchemy
that ends up being the crucible
for these creative expressions that we've shared together
and have pursued independently.
I still think,
even though we're not as integrated professionally
as we've been in the past,
our relationship still is the foundation
from which individual creations
still in a still germinate from that.
And I think that there's so much beauty
and wisdom to be glean from that,
but it also makes it...
It's a challenge.
It's a dance too, because we are so different.
How do we respect each other,
and understand each other,
and allow each other to have our own independent experiences
while also being together
and coming together to cultivate that alchemy.
Yeah, definitely.
And I think now,
and we've talked about it the last couple times
is everything and every one
and every relationship alive on this planet,
we're all going through an evolution.
So nothing's ever staying static,
we're going through evolution
and finding how are we gonna evolve,
and how is that gonna look exactly?
And so I think applying to relationships,
one of the great opportunities,
is to be open to what is on the horizon,
be open to new possibilities,
not be identifying only with the framework
of maybe how past relationships were viewed.
And I think our children are displaying that
in all this gender evolution that's going on.
Our kids are like mom, no one is straight anymore,
so don't get it.
So everything is sort of up for evolution.
And so how do we navigate in the stages when we're in,
like we're in the cocoon
or the caterpillars were in the cocoon,
and we're kind of like jelly now,
like everything's all jelly
and maybe we haven't really become the butterflies yet.
Well, I think it's a series of caterpillar
to butterfly moments.
I certainly believe that I've emerged a butterfly
from a certain type of caterpillar,
but on that subject
or theme of continual, progressive, evolution, change,
the illusion of stasis,
you can always go back.
There's always more growth to be heard, right?
So no matter how many times you become a butterfly,
you're still a caterpillar with a butterfly within you,
a more beautiful butterfly within you.
If you're willing to engage with that.
It's eternal forever.
Like eternally will be evolving.
Are we gonna make it?
We're making it, we're making it right now.
There is no make it, we're making it together.
Yeah, to make it implies a destination.
And implicit understanding that there is a stasis,
that is not reality.
Sometimes you are in that stage
before the next thing has been presented.
And so how do I navigate?
I navigate by recognizing
that every life form comes from the one breath.
And that allows me to cultivate compassion
and love for all life, including my lover, my partner.
I mean, that's really the only thing.
The only answer again, it's within,
but the main answer to every transformation is more love.
Because it's not about keeping,
if you're in illusion of keeping a relationship
in a static point, you're in huge illusion.
So it's about having the faith
to know that the evolution will arise and happen,
and that we will be led in the right places
at the right time in the right (indistinct)
Sure, and what is the balance
between the energy of allowing or surrendering to that
versus consciously trying to manage it
in a direction of growth and expansion?
Well, manage it.
I would say you could have a vision
for something beautiful that you wanted of your own vision.
You can have...
What are the feelings and the emotions
that you want to experience in the relationship?
That's really the key.
What are the feelings
that you wanna experience in the relationship?
That's what you need to identify.
Because the outward structure are crumbling
and falling and transforming in the world at this moment.
So if I was to put that question to you
in our relationship, how would you answer that?
So I wanna feel,
I wanna feel received.
I wanna feel seen,
I wanna feel loved and celebrated and nourished.
Yeah, maybe that.
And if I asked you those questions.
Well, let me just respond to that.
I mean, I think I can certainly do that
to the extent
that I haven't lived up to being able to do that for you.
So I hear that.
Thank you.
And I will do keep that in the forefront of my mind.
Thank you, beautiful.
I mean, mine's not that much different.
I would say, I wanna be loved and accepted
with all my flaws.
That's really it.
You got it.
So again, we're...
'Cause what else is there really?
What else really is there?
And those are feelings, right?
They're not thoughts.
They're not labels or titles
or a house or a boat
or what, not that I'm in.
I get seasick, I don't know, I say boat.
But it's not a thing, it's a state of being.
And when you're talking about emotions,
you get into this state of beingness,
which it's in the beingness that we can experience miracles.
I would also add to that,
that those emotions or experiences
that I wanna be on the receiving end of,
are really a function of the extent
to which I'm giving it, right?
I am not going to be feeling the way that I wanna feel,
unless I'm exuding that towards you and to other people.
So it's like what you want to cultivate within yourself,
you have to,
or what you wanna be on the receiving end of,
you have to cultivate within yourself
and share it with others.
And again, I would point to 'cause it's your Karma Yogi
coming out of you of service.
And I would just dial, click it a little bit different.
You need to embody those emotions.
That's what I'm trying to say in elegantly.
Yeah.
No, perfectly, perfectly.
So really it's this thing of as humans
we like to have consensus or opinions or attitudes
or things that you know about your partner.
Well, I know this about you and it creates a cage.
And so how can we practice being in the moment
and what would it be like
if every time you walked in the room,
you saw me for the first time, 'cause you really are.
I'm not the same woman
that you met in that yoga room although years ago.
So I'm the transformation
and the evolution of everything that we've experienced.
And so it's not the same,
same way that in the Yogi system
if you're eating Nostrum food
and the student says to the master
how do you eat the same food every day?
And the master says,
it's never the same food.
Because he's alive and connected to the moment.
And so listen, we have a lot of things
that are inciting fear in the world.
And there's a lot of systems that we believed in,
or maybe we're an illusion over,
that we have put our trust in, I guess.
And what I would say is the only thing you have,
the only thing you have is your connection to consciousness
through your own heart, it's it.
Everything else will fall away.
This relationship will fall away.
The kids will go their own way.
People come into your lives, they go.
Careers come in, they go.
But what do you have?
You have your consciousness.
And to understand that we are all part of this sacred life,
all colors, even the ones that seem like the bad,
the bad colors, all of us are.
And you can at least respect a life form.
You don't have to allow that life form
to wreak havoc in your life,
but you can have a healthy respect
for this play that we're in
and understand just how precious it is
to have a human life right now.
If you're still here,
if you're listening to this podcast,
if you have a dream,
if you have a desire, if you have breath in your body,
really, really embody that, it's a precious gift to be here.
And we all agree to come here
to be part of this transformation
and transformation is happening,
but it's our job to hold the highest vision
and it about political parties or us and them
or masculine versus feminine, or,
it's about integration and the community.
(indistinct)
(soft music)
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling profits on the planet.
Going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insight gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book,
Voicing Change, volume two.
More than mere words on paper,
Voicing Change is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of voicing Change
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying stand alone work.
And every copy comes with a chance of winning
our golden ticket sweepstakes.
Six golden tickets will be hidden within a handful of books
and will unmark a treasure chest of cool gifts
donated by several of our sponsors.
See official rules for details.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday profits,
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with it.
Voicing Change volume two available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only @richroll.com.
Let's switch gears 'cause there's not much.
I mean, that's you just put up
an emphatic period on that subject matter.
I wanna talk about your recent travels
and what's going on with SriMu,
and your burgeoning career as an entrepreneur.
Now, but before we do that as sort of a segue,
as you know finding Voicing Change volume two just came out
and I thought I would just highlight
your section in the book 'cause these photographs of you
and that photograph of us two together,
I can hold it up for the camera here.
I mean, that's my favorite picture of us
and you and your strength and your beauty.
These images were taken by
and graciously allowed to be published in this book
by the wonderfully talented Magdalena Wasinska.
Wasinska.
Wasinska, who is a Polish-American photographer
who photographed us.
I think we talked about this on the podcast before
for a magazine cover and images in this book.
Yeah, human shift
and the images in this book are images from that shoot.
And on the subject of you were talking about
the energy that you hold for somebody
as they're passing out of this life.
Magda took these unbelievable photographs
that ended up in the New York times.
And also she has shared multiple times
on her Instagram account of her mother
as her mother goes through that process.
And it's one of the most amazing things I've ever seen.
Stunning, absolutely stunning,
profound, remarkable relationship.
I think we did speak about this before,
but if you missed it, follow her on Instagram.
I'll put the link in that and show notes.
And look at these images,
they're very raw and very brave and courageous
and a wonderful opportunity for us to start
to get devotional about death.
So she's great, and I love those images.
Those images, I think make us look sort of statuesque
in a way, like the way she photographed us
was from of course
her own perspective, but from a very kind of raw way,
and they're really beautiful and I love them.
I think our wisdom shows,
an aspect of our wisdom shows.
Right, it's sort of us as elders.
Yeah, but it was cool,
but I felt, I really enjoyed that fractal
and really enjoyed that lens.
And then I think I've included a story from,
that was written for me
by a distant relative, Becky Davidson.
She has a platform called Lotimus,
which is a collection of stories.
I'd like to give her a shout out right now.
She's a beautiful mother
and her children suffered from anxiety.
And so she would create these stories for her children
that would take them on a journey
and deposit them in sort of a problem,
a challenge and then lead them out of it.
And so this is now called Lotimus,
it's online platform,
and Becky and I have been long soulmates
over many onion dip in the deep valley over the years.
And she wrote a beautiful journey about being a water tiger,
but it's not only about being a water tiger,
it's about embodying different animal forms
and what that would feel like.
So you're the person journeying
through this journey of becoming animals,
which allows us to drop our judgment of others.
Because when we drop into our sort of primal blueprint,
there is no need to convince an elephant
that he should be like a tiger.
Hmm, yeah, I think we talked about that last time as well.
Yeah, I think, we did talk about it.
Well, let's get up to speed on SriMu.
We have this incredible spread in front of us right now.
I'm so proud of this thing that you not only created,
but have mothered honestly,
and as it continues to kind of mature
and it's so cool to see so many people out in the world,
enjoying it and watching you build this amazing team
and this company that has of course these amazing products,
but also is really from an aesthetic point of view
and an energy point of view
this manifestation of everything that you are.
Well, thank you.
Oh, SriMu, she is beautiful.
She's just touches me so deeply.
So a couple things, we were invited to a wedding,
very dear friends of ours, Doug Evans.
The sprout master.
Yes.
Who is just one of the most dear energies.
He is such a lovely, lovely human being.
And he got married to his love.
And Sivan, and she Sivan B on Instagram, just in case.
Anyway, they asked me to,
they wanted to have SriMu at the wedding,
and their wedding gift was SriMu at their wedding.
So I styled some beautiful boards
with our new flavors that I have here
and created this love offering for them.
And it again they had me stand up.
They're like the first speech of the rehearsal dinner.
They're like SriMati stand up and introduce SriMu.
So there's such huge supports
and dear, dear, dear friends.
And so I introduced the SriMu,
and the SriMu just became the nectar of the dinner.
Everyone devoured it.
These were a lot of people from Holland,
from Europe who came in
and it's always lovely to see all the people enjoying
the food so deeply and so completely.
Including three or four past podcast guests,
Darren Leen, Mike Posner was there, Robbie Babar.
So lots of friends of the pod.
So sweet, I mean so amazing.
And we were there on two, it was two, two, two, two, two.
So super spiritual.
You got married on a Tuesday.
Yeah, But it...
Yeah, and the number 22
has been connected to their relationship in crazy ways.
And now they're expecting a baby who's due on a 22nd.
And 22 actually is the number of community.
And so we were really blessed
to be with a group of like-minded individuals,
all doing amazing things together, sharing.
I met a beautiful man from the UN.
Just all kinds of amazing people from the UN,
he works at the UN.
But anyway, SriMu was a huge hit.
And I told Rich kind of afterwards Doug came up,
there was an extra board left for the actual wedding
and it just got devoured,
and then Doug's texted me,
he's like SriMu was the hit of the wedding?
But I said to Rich I was kind of just so blown away
because it's food, it's plant-based cheese,
but the way that it's communicating with people
is quite beautiful to behold.
So directly from there I actually met my team managers,
Chloe, Stein, and Becca Arrife who are my flow masters,
I'm mother arc.
And they are extraordinary, extraordinary humans
who have been beside me through this entire journey.
So we hopped on a plane and flew to Memphis.
And we went through on a complete sort of whirlwind tour
of Memphis, Tennessee as a possible home for SriMu.
Explain why?
Well, SriMu model is extraordinary in every way.
The margins, the ingredients, the preparation,
the scalability, the production, the community,
the tastes, the formulation.
And I have one challenge
and that has been east coast shipping
because I'm shipping a perishable product
that has to go one or two days shipping most.
So the costs are very high
and Tom Lawrence and Ellie Lawrence,
who are our lead investors for SriMu
and my sacred finance rays current round,
who live part-time in Memphis and part-time in Telluride.
We were talking one night
about Memphis as a possible location
that could be the solution to SriMu's shipping worlds.
And of course, Memphis being the FedEx hub
and then Conrad who spoke at the wedding
and actually is a fan of the podcast.
Tom and Ellie's wedding.
Yeah, Tom and Ellie's wedding.
Not Doug's wedding.
Yeah lots of weddings too.
Tom and Ellie's wedding.
So anyway, they just set up
this sort of first class red carpet tour of Memphis.
But before I left, we received a letter from Sabine Langer,
who is her husband actually funded
the resurrection of a very famous Sears,
and Roebuck building in Memphis called Crosstown Concourse.
And back in I think the 50s,
it had Sears Roebuck, multi-level a thousand employees.
I understand from the documentary
that you could order a pair of pants
with a certain weight, size and length
and you could arrive and they would deliver
it to you in two hours.
This was a big community gathering place.
In the beginning days it was segregated,
later became integrated.
And there's a beautiful documentary
showing all the personal relationships
and life experiences that came out of this building.
So Sabine and her husband bought the building
and refurbished it.
And they have created a vertical community
called Crosstown Concourse.
And this is one of the places that I toured,
Sabine reached out and was like, I'm a fan of the podcast.
I just can't even believe
that SriMu might be coming a Memphis,
and Sebine has a restaurant called Global Cafe.
And it is women owned and refugee run by women refugees.
She also has an Italian pizzeria
and they employ from within prison reform.
So I was very excited to meet her at the beginning.
I didn't really know, I mean, I kind of knew what to expect,
but I felt I might feel the energy to be a little too much,
like all in one place.
And I was interested in my own free standing space.
So Kemp did an amazing job
and just blessed me and did all these amazing things for me.
So we found some just great places.
One was sort of more suited for production,
but gorgeous three levels.
It would've been up the bomb like incredible.
Then one was like a two storey brownstone
with five bedroom, Airbnb in the top.
You're talking about places that aren't crosstown.
That are aren't cross town.
That you toured.
Yeah, that I toured.
And then we went to Crosstown
and I experienced this vertical community
that absolutely floored me in every aspect of anything
that I've ever imagined.
They have teaching kitchens on the first floor.
Well, first let me just say
they won the AIA award this year for architecture.
They are vertical communities.
So they have residential and Airbnbs in the top floors.
They have a YMCA on the second floor.
They have a new thought high school on the second floor.
They have a listening vinyl library with 50,000 vinyls.
They have artisan residence studios where you can apply
and do a residency there for three months,
and then your art is displayed in their beautiful atrium.
They have a woodworking shop
which there is an artist there that was making
like contemporary art, wood forms like that level.
They have a printing lab.
Print making Shop.
Printing lab, where they do huge photographic prints
as big as this table.
They have art exhibits in the Concourse.
They have a performance theater, 500 seat theater,
with wood popular on the walls, they have...
What else have I left out?
A recording studio.
They have a state of the art recording studio
with a Grammy, a guy named Matt,
who's a Grammy winning producer,
they just finished it.
And in the bottom they have restaurant production
and really restaurant.
It's a really, yeah, really sort of more strong.
So of course they have one space left,
it's number 13 and it's my favorite number.
And it's like 3,800 square foot space.
And so SriMu would be able to have her first wine kombucha,
and SriMu cafe in the front 22%.
And the back 88% is gonna be production for our scaling.
The space is five times the size of my space in LA
for less money.
And there's a community of people
that are all care deeply about the same things
that we care about.
So I am extremely excited
working to find an alignment with them now.
And unless there's something better out there for me
that I haven't seen that arises,
we're gonna be moving stream his entire facility to Memphis.
Yeah, it looks incredible.
I mean, obviously I wasn't with you on this trip,
but you took a bunch of videos and showed me,
it's very impressive and super cool,
a very unique situation Of course,
I hope it works out that you can move in there
and it kinda highlight the contrast
between what it's like to be a business person in California
versus being somewhere else, right.
They just make it so hard here.
The taxes are crazy.
The real estate is insane.
The bureaucracy is bananas,
all the permitting and everything that you have to do
just to get a small business up on its feet
is incredibly onerous and discouraging to most.
And to go to Memphis and have this experience
where everything just feels so facile by comparison.
And on top of that, to be where the FedEx hub is,
to reduce the price of what is right now,
it's a premium product.
Sure.
To be able to deliver it more affordably for people,
is pretty cool.
And to have a retail space and all of that,
but are you moving to Memphis?
And am I gonna be alone in the tent?
No, I am not.
Well, you're always alone in the tent.
But you know the thing is again,
it's like we have big visions
and we have to move and it's like, this is undeniable.
And also just wanna shout out Todd Richardson
is who is the...
Cross town?
Yeah, Crosstown, like creator.
And he was history teacher
and also fan of the podcast.
And they just welcomed me with so much love.
The other thing that I need to say,
the whole time I was there my heart was pulsing love.
I was almost exhausted.
I was at Tom and Ellie's house just like,
okay, I can't take anymore love.
The people in Memphis just on the street,
conversations that I had with people there,
it was a clear fit for me
and what I'm looking to create.
In addition, a few things that I found out
that I didn't know,
one is that Memphis is the largest employer
of people of color in the country.
It is the largest employer of women in the country.
And...
That's surprising.
They have a pristine water source,
that is an aquifer that comes up from the earth,
and it is literally a food corridor,
like a pristine but food corridor waiting to be developed.
And I talked to Tom
'cause he's interested in regenerative egg,
and so it was really exciting to be having conversations
about planting trees and creating the vertical...
Integration.
Integration, and even if I couldn't plant enough trees
for it to supply everything that I needed,
for me, ceremonially to plant the trees
and to engage with the trees
in a sacred way, a ceremonial way,
this is what amplifies the taste of SriMu.
And this is why when people eat it, they feel so good.
So that is a very, very exciting expression
that's happening right now.
Some time ago you came to me
and we were talking about this evolution
of our relationship.
We have been together for a long time
and we both have our respective passions right now.
And you said, look, I wanna be in a place
where we're supporting each other
and we're allowing each other to express ourselves
at the highest level.
And you express to me like I'm here to support you
in whatever it is that you want to express.
Like, you need to go out and do that.
And I just wanna say to you publicly,
similarly, this is so exciting
and I'm here for you to support this expression
at the highest level
and to see it beginning to blossom
and this opportunity coming up
that will really allow you
to step into manifesting this
at the level that you wanna manifest it
is really a cool thing.
Thank you for that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
Appreciate that.
And I've never been to Memphis.
Yeah, I hadn't been...
We were gonna originally go,
we met Tom Shadyac at the Nantucket project.
We bonded with him.
I wanted to go visit his space,
make a little movie of the kids that he works with
and the climbing gym and all of that,
and do a podcast with him and then COVID hit
and it just hasn't happened yet,
but that was another, did you go look at his face as well?
Yeah, we went to Tom.
That was the original.
Yeah, we went to the climbing gym,
which is actually a 10 million dollar climbing gym.
Memphis rocks.
Yeah, Memphis rocks.
And my Tom Lawrence is on the board there as well,
but yeah, we'll get to,
excuse me, we'll get you there for sure now, yeah.
So it's extraordinary what Tom Shadyac has done.
And I met a lot of the kids that are there
and just lovely human beings.
And lemme just also say,
whatever attitudes are projected onto Memphis of it being,
less than LA or New York or whatever,
what I saw at Crosstown was first class.
I mean, they just blew me away.
I'm completely blunt away by what they've created
and being a multidimensional entrepreneur,
at least in my mind,
I have a big desire to work with the refugee issue.
I have a whole other thing that I wanna talk about
that I've worked on.
And also I have this new education model
that I considered burning in the fire
when our children became teenagers, I considered burning it.
But walking in a Crosstown,
both of those things were suddenly in the front
and center conversation,
because other people are doing it.
Instantly SriMu could be on three menus.
instantly I could work with Sabine in this refugee mission.
And it really is all about community
and that is a community.
So they do events.
I'm very energized as you can tell.
It gives a lot of energy and a lot of opportunity,
and I'm excited.
Yeah, it's exciting.
And you got some new flavors here.
I have some new flavors,
so we launched wholesale fourth quarter.
And so you're looking at, we have a flavor called Fire,
which mimic pepper Jack, that's really a favorite.
Also we have something called Everything,
which is similar to an everything bagel,
but in delicious H cheese.
And then the blue wheel is called Imagine,
it's butterfly pee powder.
It's more pure,
it's so interesting how experiential we are as humans,
'cause it got the purest taste
and I've served this and more men come up to me
and tell me they love the blue one.
And it's interesting to me,
because you would think it would be sort of more of a,
I don't know a feminine choice or something...
No, I love the blue one.
Like men love blue.
I love the blue one.
But they wanna eat blue, which is really amazing.
I like the Pepper Jack too, 'cause I like the spicy.
Yeah.
Turning to it.
So, but then we have a new...
But when you say...
Sorry to interrupt,
but when you say wholesale, what does that mean?
I mean, this is a direct to consumer model.
If you live in Los Angeles you can get it at Air One,
which is a fancy supermarket that we have here.
But outside of Los Angeles,
short of ordering the subscription box on the website,
it's not like a retail item.
Well, it's been.
We're opening up specialty shops and such
so there may be stores in your area.
But what I failed to talk about is the two wheel box.
This box here also we have an offering
for what we call the eternal.
We call it eternal.
And it's the three smaller wheels,
three, four ounce wheels in the eternal box.
And then in the other offering
that I'm extremely excited about
is I have the best Mozzarella that you've ever eaten
on the planet, it's called Cloud Nine.
And up until now,
it's only been part of our most luxurious box,
which is called Sacred.
And now we have new packaging.
We've moved our packaging domestic
and our new packaging comes with
an add-on of one jar of Cloud Nine
and one jar of Bonfire, which is the smoked almond cheddar,
not your grandma's cheese ball, but very, very delicious.
Now the Bonfire, the smoked almond cheddar,
you can make it into small, no meatballs,
and add it to a pasta.
You can make toasties out of it, which is extraordinary.
You can crumble it into Tofu scramble.
And then the Cloud Nine,
we have made like a crazy salad
and you can see it on the the deck.
That's a roller ball.
It's really good.
It's also insane like in smashed potatoes in a grill
and then you put this on top.
I have a video on my Instagram for that.
And it's also insane spread as a cream cheese,
but anyway, we're really excited about the new offerings
and we're gonna offer a 15% discount to your people.
Spring 15.
So SriMu.com and then code.
Spring 15 code at Checkout.
At Checkout.
Thank you for that offering.
I'm excited for you guys to try the new foods.
Yeah, that's super exciting.
It's amazing, and I know you have
like a million other formulations that...
I'm just waiting.
Yeah, you just have to get to a place
where you can really scale this thing up,
but you're raising money you've got this round,
you're raising money,
you're off to the races with all of this,
the plan the runway, you can see the runway ahead
and it's inspiring to fair witness
to somebody who just had an idea
and is really executing on it.
When a lot of people told you,
it wasn't a good idea or it wasn't possible,
or it was too complicated,
or why are you doing this?
You should do this.
And you held true to your convictions and here we are.
I see all the progress
and yet you're still just at the start line.
Just at the start line.
Yeah, a Crosstown gonna be an amazing, amazing move.
and I'm gaining traction that my guardian circle members
who are the people that are investing in
are an amazing group of humans of humanitarians.
It's my own unique way
and what I could offer to anyone who has anything
that they wanna do is it's really important
that you do it the way you do it.
You do it aligned to who you are.
Yeah, I mean, that was the question I was gonna ask you,
you've obviously had your struggles and made mistakes
and had successes, et cetera.
And although I would dab you a natural entrepreneur,
you know how to build a team and lead a team
and you have a very good sense of what to do
and what not to do.
What are some of the things that you've learned?
Because suddenly you're playing with the big boys
and you're meeting with venture capitalists
and all these private equity people.
It's a very disorienting thing,
and I'm sure there are young entrepreneurs listening to this
who are in the midst of trying to figure out
how to start a company or grow a company,
what are some of the lessons that you could impart
that you think would be helpful to those people?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's about embodiment.
It's about creating something that is coherent
with your life print,
meaning I didn't create SriMu,
'cause I thought it was gonna be a great business idea
because I wanted to get my share of the billions of dollars
that are gonna be in dairy and in dairy alternatives.
Yeah.
I created it in a very organic way.
There was a journey,
there was a journey through self healing of assist
in my neck with Aloe vera,
against all odds that everybody told me I couldn't do.
And then the journey came to your journey,
to your transformation,
and really sort of brings it back to,
this is a result of a love offering that I gave you
that I decided that I could love you
and fuel you in your races
by creating plant-based foods for you.
You're the one who went plant-based first.
I was iridic, that means I was vegetarian, you would say,
but in a healthy way.
So this is a result of all those thousands of hours,
of us going to Kauai and me being in the test kitchen
and creating thousands of recipes
over and over and over and over again.
And then the plant power way.
And then deciding that I wanted to do cheese.
And so when I meet with entrepreneurs
or established business people,
my presentation is always profound because it's me,
it's who I am, like you can't...
I'm not making anything up.
I'm not giving them figures or facts
or trying to sell them or try to convince them.
I'm telling them who I am embodied as SriMu,
and what this means.
And coincidentally it's in as sector of the market
that completely has a timeline
to become a billion dollar entity.
But I didn't start.
No, it's funny 'cause you'll come back
from these pitch meetings with big time mucky mucks.
And you're like, yeah, it was hilarious.
I told my whole story
and they're just staring at you with eyes wide open,
well, I've never heard a pitch like that before.
It happens daily.
But the thing is that the ones that don't get it,
like I don't care?
'Cause that's negotiating from a place of power,
'cause you don't need them.
You're looking for the people
who are gonna resonate with what you're trying to achieve.
No, and what I realized is,
the path you choose for your brand, it's your life.
It's the moments of your life.
And I had a meeting with Becca and Chloe a couple days ago
and we talked about a certain environment that they went to
and I was like, I didn't wanna go to that environment.
And they went and I was like how was it?
And we talked about it.
And one of them was like I said,
do you think it's important in the future?
Yeah, I think it's important.
Becca was like, yeah, I don't know.
And I said,
was attending that event a beautiful experience of life?
And then we're all like, no,
and I'm like let's not do that again.
So SriMu is a beauty brand.
It's actually a beauty brand.
Beauty is the first tenant of living a spiritual life.
We are sensory, tactile life forms.
Even masculine men want that blue color.
They want the color in their life.
We want the romance of life in a way.
And so we try to create experiences
that lead to a beautiful life.
And we made not cheese, better for our animals,
for our bodies, for the planet
and all ultimately for our children,
and it's better than cheese.
So that's why I say it's the next evolution of cheese,
but for an entrepreneur,
again, if you look at SriMu branding,
if I had gone out and like looked at other food companies,
that's the thing that I don't really,
a lot of people will say,
we'll, go out and see who your competition is.
And take an accounting of,
and I know that that's useful to some life forms,
but to me, I just had to go inside my heart
and work with my dear friend, Brian Ohara,
who did this branding
that without him I would not have my baby.
I don't know who else could have done this branding.
And he did the branding on your book.
I had created my logo
and the artwork here in the studio
and the design template for the Voicing Change book,
brilliant, brilliant artist.
And I just wanna say,
Brian is a master of logo creation
for anyone that is starting a business
or wants to create a mark.
His father was a decoder in the war with Japan.
The guy will take your phrase
and the letters become something different.
And I promise you, if you commission him,
you will get something extraordinary.
I'm not stopping working with him.
He's gonna be doing the retail design in Memphis,
he's extraordinary.
So if we can put his link in the show notes.
He just redid his website.
What is his website?
It's Ohara Glyph, Ohara Glyph.
O-H-A-R-A G-LY-P-H.
Ohara Glyph.
Okay, we'll put that on the show notes.
And the reason is because I always say,
his stuff is like a modern Hieroglyph, it's in...
Ohara Glyph.
Right, Ohara Glyph.
So what was I saying?
Okay, So going back to the knowledge
that each one of us was made in a unique life print,
that means anybody listening is unique,
there's not another one of you.
And so your most heroic mission is to know yourself,
to love yourself and to express that which is within you.
And that does not entail comparing yourself to other people.
It entails knowing yourself.
And so I knew if I created SriMu at this level
as an art form, that if I died the next day, I was good.
Like just because the quality of the product
and what I've created has the energy
and the frequency that I can lie down and I'm proud of her.
I mean, I'm fulfilled in her.
And so when I start there,
then I have the whole universe
to come off of that and do a million different things.
Anyway, different lines, all that stuff.
I think what I was getting at earlier
is this idea of you walking into these venture meetings
and people saying, well, this is how it goes.
And we don't wanna give you X,
we wanna give you the hundred X amount of dollars
for your company and you having the awareness
and the wherewithal and the respect
for this thing that you created
to not be lured into what could be considered to be a trap.
We all know entrepreneurs who have taken a lot of money
and then they're not living the life that they wanna live,
because they're sort of trapped in this paradigm
where they can't express the company in the manner
in which they originally wanted to,
because it becomes about
this board of directors and big money,
and all the pressures that come with that.
And I've seen you time and time again decline people
who actually wanna give you a bunch of money
so that you can grow this thing organically
and solidify it in the manner
in which it lives in your brain
before too many other people have the power
to kind of control you.
Yeah, well.
Is that a fair...
That's fair, yeah, that's fair to say.
And I guess what I would say is,
what I'm offering my team of guardians.
I call them guardians,
'cause I'm inviting their wisdom
and their humanitarian heart
to aid me to be a friend to SriMu.
So the people that have contributed financially
who the early investors in the company
are all very like-minded people.
Yeah, and it's key.
And what I tell them is
I don't promise them an a percentage ROI.
I'm promising them a deeply meaningful life experience,
which will include a lot of money
and a lot of energy flow in that way,
but that's not gonna be the most important part.
It's all the other community building and transformation
with the planet and our animals,
and the relieving of the suffering
and the expansion of more love in our lives.
And just the opportunity to create a humanity
where we're connected.
And that's what I'm offering,
and I was willing to wait,
and to risk missing something
in order to stay true to that.
Excellent, well, I can't wait to see this thing
continue to unfold and unfurl.
Thank you.
In the most divine alignment.
And I'm super proud of you.
It's really beautiful what you've created.
It is an expression of who you are and it's magical.
So...
Thank you, babe.
Very cool (indistinct)
I think that's a good place to end it for today.
Okay, thank you.
You feel expressed?
I feel very expressed.
You do.
And I feel seen, thank you.
Okay, good I'm already fulfilling that.
You are already.
Excellent.
If you are interested in learning more about Julie,
you can go to her website, juliepiatt.com.
She's at SriMati on Instagram and it's SriMu.
Yeah, S-R-I-M-A-T-I and the SriMu Instagram account is...
SriMati do life.
S-R-I- M-U do life.
And srimu.com, S R I M U.com is a website
for the plant-based cheese company,
where you can see the offerings
and get on board the subscription box situation,
and the code, what's the code again for the discount?
Spring 15.
Spring 15 for 15% off, yeah.
On any box offer.
Try the new flavors.
And if you're in LA you can find it in air one markets.
And if you go to...
But you cannot find Cloud Nine or Bonfire in Air One.
Right, only a couple of the wheels, right?
And if you go to Julie's Instagram account,
she's very fond of sharing reels and video clips
of the flying squirrel People.
That's like your obsession.
I'm so delighted by that.
I just...
You shared one today, the guy,
he's like on a snowboard on his a stomach,
sliding off the snow off the edge of this cliff,
and then just flying.
So cool, I love those...
In a different life, are you a squirrel person?
I think I'm definitely flying like that
in a different life, for sure.
What is that account?
Is it all one account?
I think it's squirrel, oh, I feel bad.
That is it squirrel TV?
I don't know.
Maybe Jasin confined it.
We'll figure it out.
So we give him a shout out, but...
And then also green flying dude, I think is one of them.
(Brian laughs)
It just...
How many flag squirrel accounts do you follow?
I follow at least three.
And I can't remember the other one, but it's so intense.
You know what I mean?
And it's like when you think of your challenges
or even just thinking of mysticism
and what we do in other realms
or we can...
Like a lot of people have flying dreams,
like I posted it.
Oh, flying, so...
And it's just so, I think it's so gorgeous.
I love it.
I'm delighted it's exhilarating.
I find it an awesome human expression
and I'm bowing down to all those people that do that.
But you're not gonna do it yourself.
No.
You have to do a certain amount of...
I thought about it,
but I think (indistinct)
I mean, at this point, maybe in another life.
I don't think I could.
Although, I mean, I don't wanna,
I'm not gonna say anything 'cause...
Who knows?
Yeah, who knows?
Who knows, maybe?
Well, I'm sure you'll be back on the podcast
at some point.
I hope so.
In the not too distant future.
So thank you for sharing today.
Thank you for having me.
To be continued.
Thanks, babe.
Love you, babe.
I love you.
Peace, plants.
I must stay.
(upbeat music)